it's good when you get to learn new
things and work I would hate to like
work in a job where I just didn't learn
anything new that's why I chose the game
industry it's a it's never stale that's
for sure
it's time to like what yeah I have read
about it it's a video game
oh yeah minecraft he's talking to her
about minecraft super wolf - LTS blood
loca Chompy
I hid something super cool for you -
[ __ ] did you or you accept this quest to
find my secret treasure yeah ten-four
okay you're on and I know yes
thanks Sean listen carefully you must
find the two items that will reveal
where the treasure is deal so for the
first item is here the place with any
wings that cannot fly wings oh that's
that's your - your can do it there's a
minion don't bother checking mom's
trailer it's outside
it's another flamingoes Wow I mean there
brings getting closer
am i okay not too far
this kids would be like the best search
engines and Dragons
that's not wings is it is those wings
you're way out there dude
love the energy out here with everyone
building stuff as they please
what's he saying dude I'm what now get
warm
it's gonna be the flamingo's I just
can't see what else it would be as cold
as ever
okay let's ask him for another claim yo
can you give me that last hint oh you're
serious
the item is under the building that will
blow you down you're in the middle sell
a building that will blow me down I was
in like this sculpture that's cool July
entrusted me to help build her sculpture
am I being stupid we're not too far
visit the globe it's gonna tell me
offensive [ __ ]
okay I'm gonna blow this part of town is
dead this town here
I should stay around here you go too far
you lose your walkie-talkie City my
Oh is heading clear then
ahoy matey I found a map of a way got it
okay so now the other one is sure
thing that eats the Sun
with this beef sits Tommy and often
fireworks
no I'm not Anna oh wait it's days the
solar panels
x marks the spot so this is the shop I
guess that did he do this just now
because that's the sculptor we literally
just butt up okay we'll try find that
it's all nice and it's a tracing paper
sheet with a red cross oh holy matey
I think I have the whole treasure map
that's a cool ass map you drew dude okay
so it's gonna be one of these sculptures
oh it's the new one that we just made
legacies scraps No
you're way out there dude dude
but you said I was getting closer around
here would you just tell me I wasn't too
far
let me have a little lucky ah yeah so
I'm buying all the cars maybe I just
gotta get on the other side of the cars
oh yes Alan what
it's gotta be around here he said event
you're warm big clothes Shawn
I don't even know like what I'm looking
for here I've been every just what the
[ __ ] you wanna my where is it
oh you guys have no way out
Joanne picks up all kinds of scraps from
the desert she even found a boat once
does anyone know where where he wants me
to go apparently i-15 I have no idea
where I'm going
well this is his cars you know what to
get on either side of them again you're
here
no not gasps people came here with these
and never left
no it wasn't like Oh
oh you're right there
I am maybe some man it's so cool that
people want to give a second life to
their stuff
nope
so it's like there's a car that there's
the Kasbah
and then it's like here
there's a car there should be like down
here but I can't interact with any of it
right my fans stupid car there it's like
in between these guys
yeah cuz this is that car give miss not
bad omatsu to eat without gas people
came here with these and never left
anyone know any ideas
I do not assess something on my restream
but it's saying that like no one's ready
in the chat you lying
oh you're right there once I find hope
we gonna be so obvious
there [ __ ] it's there how do I get yes
people can know oh my god I gotta
believe that something's very long
without so difficult to find
there it is hidden by some dust
particles whoo
looks like some things buried here what
is
yes I have found a not a prospector but
it looks like the real deal you asked
for it
[Music]
gotcha
we'll help her ad with the groceries
where's wish can he come from down there
over there
I can hear a car approaching but I can't
see one
ah there it is
run me over watch out I'll let him know
we're back got empty that truck hello
[Music]
hey good morning
howdy Shawn hey what's up how was the
town trip hate these trips people look
at us as if we're aliens here come the
sand people the deserters have returned
with offerings from dust capito Joe Lee
I missed you
next time you're coming with us huh
we'll see looking good what's your
secret defying death on a daily basis
hydrating oh right I can't forget your
goodies hey thanks angel here ah you're
the man Karen catch you later
take care Hey
so how did you guys like UNITA Canyon it
was great it was amazing so many stars
so quiet
good call care I mean you like it
stargazer glad you got to see that hi
mom how was the town town life always
sucks but we got something for you
big fast oh yes thanks David
you want to play catch Danny Boy totally
me and dad always used to play but I'm
Way better enough oh yeah cause each II
no matter what he's been through he just
wants to be a kid and play yep Daniel
hasn't been like this in forever you've
all been a good influence on him about
time you boys went camping
Oh Daniel didn't get scared by all the
critters yeah he was like playing with a
scooby-doo duffer and he can defend
himself you're right behind he does like
to show off maybe too much
you boys have been here over a month and
I still can't get over Daniel's skills
does that kind of scare you me god damn
right it does never met someone with a
superpower before I try to be a good
influence not always easy but he listens
to me I don't know if I did right guess
you never really know listen
raising a kid is the toughest job in the
world trust me
combat was easier
we got kids you didn't tell me you had
kids
how many none I was a stepdad or in her
case a step douche before her mom died
we never got along she was angry I was
stupid
we were like oil and water and she was
always starting [ __ ] guess that's hard
for a kid to get in your father
especially one like me I just had no
clue how to deal with her but eventually
what's the word guys about how we all
face anyway you can't go back
nope thanks for talking David better
start my delivery now found some weird
snacks in town Arthur's gonna freak I'm
not food shopping especially when it's
in a shelf and I'm like oh different
statue okay time out oh I'm gonna melt
that was awesome mom now I know why they
don't play baseball on the desert you
throw way better than Sean yeah
we're not done out here yet let's get
this food inside before it melts no
problem
she is so cool nothing Joanne is so cool
he's gonna get like so exercise the heat
is so cool
you're way too easy bro whatever can't
help it if I like can just be you and I
no I'm just saying don't get too cozy
here this is a pit stop restaurant I
know the games logging
let's mark that everybody takes turns
shopping
dry cat food isn't a cat around here
today which is pretty much wrong or she
loved working with kids we're gonna put
the food away or just a new statue that
woman is amazing
actually I rented it too bad there's
nobody my age here but this is where
people come to get old
I have to admit I do miss that Pacific
Northwest weather sometimes yeah I bet
you've been here over a month now what
do you think of our little oasis
everybody's everybody's very cool and
Hawaii different can't even believe
nobody's freaking out about Daniels
power well Shawn it's still hard for me
to wrap my head around it
but people here are not gonna get in
your space they have their own past too
that's why people come here from all
over the country for their own reasons
not perfect but it works
it is so peaceful out here guess that's
what everybody's really looking for
peace you're probably right
yes I still feel like we're really
privileged out here there's bad [ __ ]
going on in this desert yeah I don't
think you can ever really get away from
everything
you can't escape reality even here we
just live slightly apart
so how did you end up here do you guys
like that like most of us I was first
brought here by someone Maggie
after I failed to make it in New York I
was lucky enough to meet her down in
Florida she's had a tough life
this place was her cat away she's long
gone now but her name is still written
all over this place well thanks for
bringing us here
Oh Sean I'm glad I was able to help you
by the way can you grab your brother so
we can all talk everything we're gonna
get fish just looked we could spend this
day together just the three of us oh
maybe she's leaving because she's like a
big brother to super wolf we need you at
Karen's trailer copy oh my gosh my
entire son's ohm you're right that is
the same guy from life is strange one
the step douche Chloe's stepdad I can't
believe it how about a truck is even
notice you in let's pack them it was
good to see he took some responsibility
finally
the Chloe's mum didn't die is she
what
I should have camped near that little
creek it was so perfect now you'll need
a good night's sleep after all this when
the cars just half a mile down the path
this place makes for a pretty cool
bedroom now yeah I'm eat oh sorry just
got one last thing to show you guys I
can't get enough of this place huh come
on Daniel
give me your hand she's got something
bad to tell her no I could tell by her
face slow down won't you walk too fast
more walk less talk I couldn't never say
that but my mom she's always telling me
slow down guys she's like I am 50 or
knows now this is nature's art
the density come here like last night
and they would have seemed so quiet
except for the birds of prey serious if
we're lucky
yeah well we'll get to see Birds
she said be careful hunters out here the
wolf brothers can't be trapped you'd
help us
hmm you must hide
all the time there's not a lot to do but
it's enough for me good thing Joanne
likes to come with me oh I bet she would
be fun to go hiking with well not when I
go too fast she's all about the journey
we usually find a good pace usually
Joanna's like Shawn they make art so
they stop to look at stuff you're way
more like next yeah I am like you Daniel
so let's hurry up
wait or maybe this is when we find out
that she has some sort of power to mmm
Andy Andy
Adarsh
something's memory doesn't work well
damn I haven't thought my memory works
dad well I think you're getting your
words mixed up just like me tonight I
love to come here to get away from away
yeah isn't this uber and can't be nice
man
it's the best buy let's sit down
so hey I do appreciate that you guys
stuck around this long thank you
I don't want to say you can say you
regret leaving us now from that yeah it
was good to get to know you better see
your life this place is pretty cool
it's like Ferry Road but nicer I got to
learn about living in a desert hiking
canyons counting stars you're a
natural-born Explorer it's hard to
believe you two are actually out here
with me I was lucky we had this chance
just know I love both of you so much I'm
proud of who you are and where you're
going
she wants us to leave she's like please
no stay
I don't wanna keep you I never wanted to
keep you do you think oh maybe I'm just
being worried I'm pessimistic by the way
if you wanted to you could come with us
to Mexico that would be cool I would
love to come see you settled into a new
home but you're almost there okay but
it's not gonna come with us I have to be
upfront with both of you what happened
in Haven point is catching up on us huh
what do you mean when we were in town we
saw some stories in the papers
the feds are definitely tracking us down
in the region shoot and they'll find us
what does that mean do you have to leave
what about her figures always on the run
nice can last forever so
this is it Tina
we'll leave tomorrow
can you hand me that back
that's why I brought you back here
I made these for the fourth of July but
this is better
oh I love those things
whoa awesome cool
let's light up the sky
she can
[Music]
okay I was just being pessimistic
[Music]
[Music]
I thought I really did think that she
would have some sort of power
and that's why white Daniel did but I
guess I was wrong
so it would have been like inherited
turns out she's just an average woman
[Music]
doesn't she needs to leave as well but
guys all set up to leave no so that's we
have to leave again I think I'm kind of
scared
oh honey
what are you gonna do now take off and
hide not this time
there's a sad story on the matter so
I'll do what I have to to help you it
won't be easy crossing that border so
I'm gonna give you a head start on the
police wait
Wow oh she's gonna be bait cops are
after me too what happened in about so
they can catch me instead of you
fair trade mom well go to jail we're
helping us it's not about me right now
we need to get your asses to Preta Lobos
it's pretty nice of her
you don't have to do this Karen I let
you guys down before not this time I
knew what I was doing she's redeeming in
that way looking for your brother I felt
it was the right thing to do and I feel
the same today I tried to live by my own
rules no matter what
I don't expect you boys to be like me
but try to stay true to yourselves this
is your life don't let anybody get in
the way
yeah it's really nice song
then what should we say
[ __ ] the rules
go to whatever we can't that's fair
it is no no I took care of Daniel
all the way from Seattle to Arizona
nobody can ask for a better brother or
son okay this is the last roundup wait
let me see brighter Joanne all right I'm
gonna go do one last check up on the
truck before you hit it and don't forget
what we talked about
it's your life Shawn you should go see
David you know something for you okay
- right - Karen yes DS oh damn look what
that money she deserves that I know
you're better with words than me but
still here it goes
oh I get to write the note this is cool
I think it took me some time but I think
I get why you are who you are maybe
we're not that different
please don't give up on your freedom
okay it's the best thing you've taught
us
we'll reach you once we find our own
freedom
thank you so much love Sean no
well dismiss me yeah that I am gonna
burn or the already patch FBI Nevada
please the search if a woman had two
teenage sons and said after a suspicious
fire destroyed a church oh honey they
need okay so we've already looked at all
this stuff okay dude don't forget about
David
not everything
this place has too many adults
but I'm gonna miss it
shine hey Karen said you wanted to see
me yeah
but go grab that police scanner inside
first I got to put these new plates on
the car
sure come on I'll join you when I'm done
I'm ready him he's way too nice and like
chills out so it Arthur said David could
fix anything
he hopes
see I was like a proper control freak
wasn't me hmm they look cool I wonder
which one is his daughter that Chloe I
don't know guys I'm really not sure
cool portraits didn't think David had a
taste for the Arts
yes actually because that is max isn't
it I wonder what's in their circles
effectively face yeah
me and David won't be sharing any
playlist what do you want us to get ha
sweet is that is that a mandolin
must be his wife there she is times
taking us Wow Claire sweetie
I love it she was so cool I wonder what
David got this police scanner
okay how does this thing work
okay we got a search between 140 and 160
[Applause]
dusty
wait is this it
Oh he can listen a spy on the cops all
the way to Mexico mm thanks David
you big rebel
oh you might be right probably was a
banjo banjo
mom's car is all ready to roll
did you get any scanner right yep Bri
and I found the police frequency how
about that
good job now you'll always want to know
what they're up to no surprises on your
way to the border all right this is the
fastest route when you get there
cross between these two stations now you
have to exit the main road and drive
through the desert for a while but
Karen's car should be okay you got all
that hmm sure
think so Sean you have to know the
police are on your ass you only get one
chance here I'm not trying to be a dick
just honest I know David Thanks
here have a seat
but don't mean to order you around that
habits die hard and yes that was
suspicious when Karen showed up with you
two but after watching you and your
little brother for a while I think I get
what you're going through I guess if I'm
Katie they would say that she destroyed
my bed a hurricane no my stepdaughter
and her friend were among the only
survivors doesn't know that I chose the
ending
we lost everyone else she eat
sorry I used a Musudan running away hey
frog frog the roads straight away never
to look back well I was trying to
rebuild what are you in Arcadia Bay then
how did you survive did you stay in
touch
do you get along now yeah yeah took me a
while to acknowledge the past was the
past and move on like they did once I
realized that I reached out to them and
we made peace with each other I stayed
here for a while it felt good to connect
with my daughter at last you guys remind
me of them in a way and I don't want to
[ __ ] things up this time Sean I'm gonna
do everything I can to help you get out
that's my duty now but I want to be
straight up with you okay yeah well of
course I know you guys got screwed but
you think nobody will ever believe you
the truth is on your side you and Daniel
can't just hide out forever is that how
you see yourself in ten years if you
step up and face the law you can be free
sooner than later
oh no I don't want tell it something
you've come too far now we just want in
your life that's it
I understand I do I'm trying to be the
adult you're too young to be dealing
with all this and Daniel is growing up
fast too fast
that's what I'm worried about
you made it here yeah I mean Daniel seem
thinned I like him oh sorry
I really have to take this
hey sweetie what's up I was at Chloe
sweetie is that so weird that they
finally get along I mean it's nice but I
hate what YouTube did to you because I
barely get views but hey don't like you
having fun thanks for uh you didn't do
anything it's my fault birdy I don't
upload enough and I don't play like I
don't play you know like lots of us too
and stuff so it's kind of my fault I
don't really blame YouTube but at the
same time you know I've been chasing for
my career to become a game designer so I
just like I just didn't have the time
I'm gonna try though I'm gonna try and
at least upload once a week and I do
stream once a week so you know I do my
bit at the same time it's nice having a
small community because I don't know I
feel like women a bit more connected cuz
I actually get to like talk to the same
issue kind of people which is quite nice
what am i doing although don't get me
wrong it would be lovely to have this as
a job but I just I just it's so freakin
difficult and also it's terrifying if
you have this as a job because if
YouTube decide one day that they're just
gonna do my toes other stuffs then it's
basically the same as you just being
fired what was I supposed to do
I've been just yapping don't hit my
clothes
don't stretch yourself out story of my
life now I want to I want to actually
give it a go
is that the same person who wrote her
back in Beavercreek I also have like
this perfectionist quality word I don't
like to prove content that is like
half-assed
oh I don't think you read this before
the brain she was that close such she
had to pay all that money back uh who
was she gonna get someone with her poems
we regret to inform you at this breach
of contract means we should no longer be
publishing the collection as part of our
new policy is that why your inability to
submit your poetry manuscript of the
other way to rave is repressed by the
contracted deadline no she didn't do it
in time oh damn that sucks thanks for
subscribing frog frog
and won't be weird to be back on the
road with Daniel let's go to the car
gasps where is a car behind you
go to the car
is this it is it let's check you out one
last time
wait should we say goodbye to the other
people are they still around
oh this these two dude sit down here hey
guys
wish I could be as cool in this wise as
these guys when I get older I came by to
say else we're taking off today no
you're not yeah everything okay yeah
just time to go [ __ ] what you know
and Daniel could stay longer
thanks but the sooner we cross the
border the better no worries no worries
[ __ ] that's all we're gonna do until
you make it
we will thanks to you and everyone here
you gave us a place to breathe Sean I
won't drag the sound and get bitter
besides you and Daniel will be back to
visit right
no way we'll try I'm glad this place
will be our last us memory you and your
little brother will always have friends
here and a home okay I'm done babbling I
just hate goodbyes I know you're both
gonna have a great life in Mexico you
better we we're gonna make it work
[ __ ] I'm gonna miss you guys
take care you hear watch out for Daniel
he needs you be safe and send us a
postcard of the beach I will mark that
dude
not like it Joanne
I don't know come on there's the first
thing that comes to him up hey what's
going on mMmmm taking a look at this
baby with hindsight so what are you soon
well looks a bit off or something I
agree something's not right
I'll figure it out or give it up I love
it so you guys leaving now yeah just
wanted to say goodbye yeah that's sweet
you're so sweet
your brother is so sweet having you boys
around it's the sweetest thing this is
for all your help
really whoa do I get anything your name
is on a way bigger sculpture for
everyone to see that's true I didn't
think about that yeah your brother
needed a little something to remind him
of the artist inside hmm
wicked okay one big hug and get out of
here before we all start crying like
babies Thank You Joanne for everything
just please take care of yourself and my
special apprentice your worries we
always do hey is it okay if I hang out a
bit longer if it's okay with her are you
kidding
I need more help so long Shawn did what
we need to go now don't we hayla freaky
it was wolf because they're wolves but
um no the original characters aren't in
this however Chloe's stepdad is he's in
the caravan over there I'm no one it
would be cool if they bumped into each
other yeah zom said that just now
okay I'm now I'm going to the go to the
car
time to leave
Hey Oh need any help just checking out
the levels and cleaning up the filters
they're about to cross the border into
Mexico
I didn't know you were such a gearhead
Oh Sean this is basic car maintenance
and I may not be a pro like your father
was but I I got some solid skills I have
two out here yeah sorry I'm the newbie
my temper really got into cars and stuff
Esteban was obsessed with his engines
that doesn't mean you had to be too
yeah
he only wanted me to find my own way
whatever that was Georgia had more time
listen Esteban loved you and Daniel for
exactly who you are he would be proud
that you're going back to his homeland
today
did you guys ever go to Mexico together
we talked about going but never did
he said growing up there was hard but he
loved it I don't know anything about
Mexico it's scary
Shawn you're carrying the weight of two
people on your shoulders now it's okay
to be nervous I'm just tired of running
causing trouble everywhere we go Daniels
power is overwhelming and we don't know
where it comes from
but you do know your brother you'll be
there for each other
it scared shitless I'm not even sure I
can do this okay if we can start a new
life but I'm the only one that can take
him to safety your brother sure isn't a
little kid anymore
he had to grow up too fast
he wants to be equals and you guys are
gonna have to work together
he may even help you make it that's true
maybe you're right you'll figure it out
like you always do okay better get back
to my tune-up
all right I'll make one last round
before we leave
oh I already did that I just made the
round uh yeah uh my car broke down on
the way Wow
it's okay now but it's just so old
there's so many things wrong with it so
I'm gonna have to sell it parts probably
and semi T's coming up there's no way
it's gonna pass the MOT but then again I
said that last year and it did pass the
IOT so we'll see but it's nothing I'm
gonna look for another car Daniel do you
copy
it's time to wrap it up
so did you get to say goodbye to away
yeah kind of sad I know are we leaving
yet we have to and I know come here mom
I I'm gonna miss you I'll miss you too
Danny
it was amazing to spend this time with
you I'm so damn proud of you both and
what you're gonna do with your life
and if you ever need me I'm just around
the corner okay mom thank you
sorry I didn't see you talk about it on
discord did you say on the patreon chat
because icon sometimes I'm general
there's just like so much going on Shawn
but now don't worry husband I can talk
about it
[Music]
oh yeah of course hooker why wouldn't I
she's about to sacrifice freedom for us
for being there thanks for letting me
son that's not even a choice why would
you know hey Gabriela let's hit the road
is everyone gonna come and see us off
yep
reggae take care boys
[Music]
stay safe so if Karen is going to go in
VR like decoy
I guess she's coming later
hey Casper
merit
okay I'm not gonna lie I totally forgot
the Klan now David told us I forgot it
so I hope you were listening Gabriela I
didn't realize it was David but he's so
different
Hey
is something wrong of course he's scared
we're almost there okay
that's the last time I have to say that
I don't care about that so
what's the problem
what are we gonna do on quarter all of
us we don't know anybody they have
family that's dangerous how long do we
live there
I'm not gonna say we live like kings
no more hurry that's the maid here no
more running and I know so
what are we gonna do for money and stuff
we've got money but I will get a job I
get a job man it won't be hard you can
probably go to school dude I can't even
speak Spanish how can I make friends or
do anything if I can't talk you pick it
up quick
I'll teach you man
you think so
yes could you fit in everywhere we go
and we'll get to hang out too
well that sounds okay
I guess Daniel I can't scared to you
know but we'll be
we'll be fine
okay
I trust he's such a good brother
and basically father figure
[Music]
[Music]
I wonder how old
Shawn is supposed to be in
[Music]
he's driving with his power the house is
scary
[Music]
automobile
[Music]
if you guys ever eaten cactus it tastes
amazing
oh okay at least I wasn't the only one
yeah Bradley didn't realize that it was
david straight away neither I felt I
thought better of myself oh he's about
18 okay fair enough I guess that's why
so no he just kind of taught himself how
to drive but I guess now it won't be a
massive deal if anyone sports and
driving how are they gonna get over the
wall what's so big now just give me a
boost
you just have over it easy dude it's
just a giant fence except it won't keep
us in
oh yeah they've got the radio
Hey
Shawn yes why would they build this well
you know it's a border man is there a
wall like this up north no not really
this should last until port the locals
unless our car breaks down in the desert
wait but how are we supposed to drive
our car through the wall like don't miss
something
Wow can people join when they're 16 in
America this is the opposite we're at
the end Rob is 17 here I guess it's not
that different
[ __ ] I didn't think there would be more
than a barbed wire fence out here yes
you just
get down you also destroy ends there
doesn't seem to be any other way in yeah
I don't we'll find a random hole
somewhere say
so
here we are Daniel the end of the road
finally let's get out of here
yeah take it easy you can do it
[Applause]
dude it's hard
[Music]
well he did pick up a whole tree
did he not I can't it's alright
take your time stay
focused
there was no option for him to lift it
some
only the story only this time
there
the policy of the brave
beautiful your right to broth almost hey
it's okay it's okay
just breathe this is not like weeding
out this Mary breathe
Wow
we did it we [ __ ] that [ __ ] up
yes he folded it like it sucked nutbar
packages that he did Gabriella
it's old things - you gonna be alright
Tom the hardest part thanks for taking
me down here Shawn nah we did it
together man
come on let's go back to the car
did you not see her pick up a whole tree
Zoey just swimming in the ocean
me neither let's go it's the rest of the
car come on that would be cool we could
just walk to the beach
I really want to go right okay I'm dying
to get some choco crisp
it'll be do you Daniel and then you'll
talk to me Daniel
talk to me I think it just grazed him
Daniel I think he just raised his um
who are you did you shoot my brother
oh [ __ ] Madison I told you was a [ __ ]
kid get off of me get off of me
well there's no easy my brother he's
okay
bullet just grazed not move if you want
to keep that on comprende keep an eye on
the wall
these [ __ ] blew it up so their
friends can cross Daniel
sowhat's know we were trying to get
America
we're leaving going to Mexico I swear
wait wait
you're trying to break in to Mexico
that's [ __ ] funny
she's not gonna believe us now it's not
legal to blow on walls
that's called terrorism
so tell I I don't know give me some more
time
you're not talk you can't arrest us
no but we work with them and they sure
appreciate our help
looks like no one's coming for now
anyway don't waste your energy
I bet the portal had a big plan for you
mr. Madison come on we have to deal with
this kid oh stop nudging don't move
get it off stop was it good not easy
[Music]
hey Dad what the [ __ ] is going on
where's Spencer he's off duty today why
listen uh we have a deal
he knows yeah I heard about this crap
not happening anymore
come on man do what the officer says
[ __ ] how old is he he's alright officer
don't worry
shut it you're both coming with me to
the station what are you kidding what
they're illegals fuckstick
what I think
we're American actually
take a breath you okay now wow he's a
good car know what I'm sorry are you
Sean oh no oh no Sean he is oh no you're
under arrest
damnit dumbass hey George
please stream so I do need to figure out
what I'm gonna be streaming next but I
was gonna maybe try and get my ps2 to
work play some old-school horror games
damn it my lights gone
yeah oh
I probably end up doing a poll on
Twitter so all I could do was carry on
planes
don't look
yeah why should laughter speech in yeah
see
Josie do so Carla yes to free a little
IKEA so oh she's fine
Oh Encantada hmm so he's Sean come out
the same to see Hovis tone in your 30s
onions Esme we need to use Bernardo
cerca del modo you study you know you
Bernal Emperor Maria see if we're ever
gonna be oh no Williams yeah yeah
I already have anyone who's gotten
Syracuse Utica serious
tranquilo Mingo Jimmerson Daniels ninos
Oh course I wouldn't be as simple as
just blowing the wall up and walking
through hope that Campbell's almost done
with the paperwork then we're out we're
not coming back oh thanks I'll remember
that this place is [ __ ] gross jeez
wonder how many people have been locked
up in here
Savan cuanto tiempo you know sworn I
heard a key no it's just my primera vez
content on cosa you are going mr.
primera vez samuri Mazda said and this
year Tony connects a little caramels
jaghana Mexico man he Co miss taro
porque entonces on Gringo's say national
sake pero ahora tenemos que irnos Thomas
Capano de algo matter service Thomas
cruzar la Frontera por que necesitan
cruzar done the spell of Amenti por las
mismas Rizzo mosquitos no podemos super
turn things over even in la miss area in
Mexico la violencia tiene muchos formas
no se puede vivir rossi condor merman
often say Australian national piranhas
Pandya most famous serious I'm espero
que irnos no sorry a mascara on master
12 lo pero como una vida de Vilmorin
master only ho oh oh yeah
violence everyone its kind of scape it
his location Apapa safer they Mexico
cuando mullions bothers her ganar Scylla
Vida purchase a fixed [ __ ] I was super
villain attack or supuesto better stay
cool rocket to lose my son is para you
say go nosotros heroes any marked amigo
Rallo and may he go no I said facil para
ustedes some policemen if we go a
question Jesse mother Harlow pero I had
my computer complete to Suenos
er nothing worse when you sake Sean as
vivillon este pais toda tu vida con
Padre Mexican you're a los tiempos on
candy - como Chris gave a certain in
Peru
- this worth bikini poverty guru chief
woman's brain integrals no comprende
condom you do wanna make it a solo lo
siento mucho
my mother's extra narrow - Katra around
master opera radio optimus see funciona
oh [ __ ]
enough now it's America we speaking
we're just talking
no the problem is you people breaking
into my country which I do not steal or
live at you your home deal no I am so
[ __ ] tired you only come here to
cause trouble and we have to pay for
your welfare you all want a free ride
and that makes me sick
for pissing people like this like they
do on sorry society to raise our child
in a safe country that's all we're
looking to close the home that's what
you people always say but the facts
speak for themselves
my dad was an immigrant and he worked
his ass off raised a family and made a
business yeah and his son ended up in
jail what a role model thanks for
proving up him because he got damaged
yeah you heard the slick like like
animals I don't think I have a choice
I want the safest country for my
children see you love your family like
us we don't go walking hundreds of miles
in the desert and risking everything for
no reason we do it for arts Oh Montez
tell me where that's on there's so many
people I owe you and so no Harris I have
nothing in common with me and my family
hi Maddie what'd you say see there you
go take it easy entity you so loved us
imperialist ghosts as part of things
the Arizona know about it whether you
people like it or not we're not gonna
give you a break you're in jail too
exactly loser loser
sure kids up down here with them you
know us we're helping you got day mate
you have the right to remain silent
so [ __ ] use it okay all right D
you're up how's my brother don't worry
about him now turn around hands behind
your back
okay let's move it
yeah it actually surprised or whatever I
wanted until Isis people know I'm like
where's my weight they still do this
thing but it is and that's why lost some
blood we still need to talk about stuff
they're taking care of him at the
infirmary you want coffee
okay either Gabby be right back
[ __ ] my bro got a fan will help you
sorry because my name is yazmin I
literally got to him what he got to me
and I walked out my front door and he
went oh thank god you're white and I was
like what like why is that the first
thing that comes to your head so tired
of this [ __ ]
anyway put on a [ __ ] show [ __ ] is it
morning already so great then can't seem
Daniel since yesterday how can i braid
them of course not yeah I'm not Daniel
leather has special powers no point in
getting these off there's cops
everywhere
it doesn't matter if you're if you shoot
a kid you're so gonna get put in jail
there you go
looks like you need it Thanks Siana so
lightweight Isis thank you Faisal say
you've tried it seriously it's not a big
mug oh wow yeah well coffees gonna make
it feel so much better
my baby need to go to the toilet
it says drink more because then I get an
excuse to go to the toilet
jeez
that's quite a crime spree it's hard to
believe what kids can do nowadays
killing that officer in Seattle to
handle icing a motel room yeah
caught in a another weird explosion at a
pot farm in California then you join a
religious commune in Nevada Oh which
ends up burned to the ground and we're
not even halfway down the list one of
those things you could get away with but
not all that
it sounds crazy but I can explain
explain it to agent Flores she's on her
way now she spoke to your mother who
took responsibility for the church fire
so let her
she says a lot who cares you don't have
any proof yeah I don't drag her into
this okay she's a good person
hey it's not up to me kid
listen I feel sorry for you I really do
but denying what you did will only make
things worse
why what's it my fault isn't anyone's
fault all I did
well what's try to serve I'm not even a
douche bag baby you know I read the
report you claimed that officer Matthews
death was an accident so why didn't you
wait for the police
cuz no one would have believed no one
would have believed what happened we
didn't either
well it's too late now your case is
filled to the brim with evidence
good news is your brother's too young to
be prosecuted they'll end up with your
grandparents if they want him but you're
facing a shitload of years between bars
at least he'll get a life
oh he must be here uh what I don't get
is how to kids can destroy so much stuff
I mean anywhere you went something blew
up
seriously
how Alexi for what can I say we're super
villain
[ __ ] it what do you want me to say we're
super villains
we can't help but destroy gym yeah right
I bet the judge will love this maybe
he'll give you special treatment whoa
what is that it's a I don't think you
should keep your ass in that seat
I'm shot okay yeah yeah I'm okay just a
little
you gotta go thanks Nana let's go
is he okay I wanted to rescue you but I
have to use my power I didn't want to
hurt his okay don't worry
it's the old did he just say that
[Music]
who's gonna
yeah yeah yeah okay okay Carla and
they came all the way from Mexico
and God thrown in jail for asked for
the others
there shall we try to make peace with
these morons asks for
the others
they're the ones who try to shoot you
you got what
- go - hey
I want to wait aren't you supposed to be
in a hospital
you look like place hold on we're gonna
get you out
[Music]
Daniel
watch it
gracias muchas gracias
it's better Mickey I don't know whether
it's unless we had a to out because I
mean they obviously source pardon me
think then maybe a good jeweler show
them that Mexicans really aren't that
what the [ __ ] are you
I'm not gonna take that
I don't want to free them uh Steve cuz
everything they've done now [ __ ] it I'm
not gonna be nice and nice nice nice
he's out for the count
[Music]
[ __ ] oh shoot
hand up do not move wait Shawn
stay back Daniel
Oh God gonna find something to stop
[Music]
to cheer oh [ __ ] don't let's stay
worship sting wish it sting wish
everyone put him in there no
see much heard the man now let's move
Shawn I think our things right there but
Hey
[Music]
don't move I'll be right back okay but
be quick
[Music]
let's go it's got this Cusco come on
short without it yo-yo no way we'll be
so dead if we didn't have Daniel's power
I hate that he has to use this for all
this [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
take it out Daniel if you speak
okay go go
let's roll Daniel
hurry shot dry
okay so we gonna go back to the hole now
you know nobody is chasing us yeah
emergency bulletin for every area
[Music]
all right
we still go into Mexico
yeah
I thought that would be a choice for us
then I was like we can stay here in
Canberra this game play she knocked them
out with the metal cabinet fireworks
Sean it's the fourth of July our
first one without dad
you're right
remember how he was sewing the fireworks
every year
he always made us grow too early so we
could get a good spot I know
she's so corny
he said he was proud to live in this
country
everyone that sees Daniel uses powers
they must just think they're going crazy
Oh oh dear
Shawn what are we gonna do
I mean it's quite bloody obvious they're
trying to go to Mexico they came back to
the border
[Music]
I'm sorry I get fries sorry they should
not assume hug day
in Seattle
the date that was shot
I think about it every day
and I would give anything
to change what happened nothing
I'm sorry for my mistakes
I tried my best
I swear sure
[Music]
I'm so proud of you Annette just like
dad would be
we both earned a lot together you can
make your own it's gonna make it if we
surrender they will separate as I tell
you
and if that happens
promised me that she will always do the
right thing okay don't waste your power
be smart like you already are I don't
want to be separated
whatever happens I always remember
that you did you gasps oh gosh
come on
so what are we gonna do how does the
story of the wolf brothers end oh I'm
gonna have to make this decision no no I
don't know he's gonna have to just like
kill a bunch of people like he crosses
the border we're gonna have to make
Daniel do it for the next we surrender
the movies separated but Daniel will
still get to live a full life because
he's too young to be predicated
I'm kinda thinking that we surrender
ah sounds crying a little bit need to
cut onions time I don't know should we
surrender what should we do
I mean I kind of won across the border
just because we've finally gotten so far
but at the same time I just feel like if
we do that we're just gonna mess up done
you're more we might have to still be on
the run we might not even make it don't
know how many people he'll kill in the
process but then if we surrender then he
gets to live his life but without
without Shawn
I got this is why I played games with
you guys
Jonathan Jonathan and Casper say it
across the border
mantan says that more than two endings
so I wonder if there's a way that we can
surrender and still be okay
yeah I definitely bad have you trying to
cross the border
Oh
get rid of cried when you're playing
this I can't don't run across the border
I felt like that's ah this is a hard
decision to make
I don't know man there's like seven
endings in the game I feel like the more
ethnic ending is to cross the border but
the more logical ending is to surrender
your choice yes I know I know I wouldn't
wanna be your skin right now
hey I think I'm gonna have to surrender
even though it's like a really boring
choice but I just want the best for
Daniel he's already had to do so much I
think to get enough time she's like
that's my trick those way drew a quaint
does coin toss Neverending chimney says
I've never I never seen this game but I
don't I don't know the context but I'm
gonna see across the border thank you
for chiming in I guess I could flip this
SD card see where it lands Tessa
going to your stream ah
I guess rain top is close to the water
bottom is surrender I'm probably just
gonna flip this over the summer he would
not be able to find again its surrender
guys it landed on surrender so we're
gonna surrender it because right now
they probably do a family decision but
whatever okay see that so many puzzle
it's right here he's he would end up
killing them
oh I don't know
I get it
it's not who you exactly
we're not criminals yeah which is kids
Oh
ultimate is kind of like that decision
was like - Manuela - what place we want
to live you're my brother
love
I love YouTube Sean it's gonna be your
promise
promised for real this time
I do
we're doing the right thing
just
try remember what I taught you
maybe
only the good [ __ ] I will
I swear
underneath I said on your knees
I'm sorry about all bass we're gonna
look after your brother that's my word
okay he's ready
sure no audio yeah he's gonna be fine
Daniel you're not a little wolf anymore
never forget who you are death
I feel like I made the wrong choice
oh no you get something for the
grandparents that's cute
I'm toaster for this
give me five minutes
it's just a day
ah
is that Daniel graduating that's cute
[Music]
I think it just set me off because I
thought about how he like had to lose
his dad and then his brother and I was
like oh that's real sad and I don't know
whether his mom got put into jail as
well
okay so she's there at least
wait to get an out he's gonna get life
why are we so much
[Music]
oh and Lisa didn't get life that's good
thing
this has to be a very long time for that
new life
[Music]
now these days
I just really like put you into someone
else's shoes that doesn't mean you go
through or we're done so emotional
you think like a badass than I he looks
like a real supervillain
[Music]
there's no there can't be the same words
at least no they won't be you because
they are back in America I guess in a
way that's kind of a good thing because
that guy was saying how much ago is
really difficult to live in because of
the violence and stuff so at least they
don't have to try and train set up there
like still we were there
[Music]
she's so old and why is the mean sure
what I mean
[Music]
[Music]
I can't imagine where let's be like
laughter
just try and go back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is he going awesome
[Music]
Sally's like Don you know specific
so much
he still gets to be a kid
you know he's so silly happy Daniel oh
maybe not now
so I'm guessing Sean wanted to go off on
his own adventures to get over
everything
exactly Wesley yeah they're not running
anymore
Shawn can begin a new life yeah
and Daniel got his new life straight
away so that was good
now I want to see what the other pendant
was like ah that was such an irrational
jennie-o so yeah see that
these games I hope they do it's not
making that I think they're really
important I they touch on subjects I
really need to be spoken about and like
I keep saying in a game you really get
the chance to be put in someone else's
shoes that you literally cannot in any
other way I mean even through film is so
dissipative you were I knew you will
never make the same kind of emotional
attachments as you do in games like this
like I will never forget the time I
think I was like episode 2 or maybe he
was even one where they went to that gas
station and I got the opportunity to
steal some food because Daniel was
really hungry
but I didn't because I didn't want to
break the law whatever for them you
still got accused of stealing just
because you are Mexican and to me that
like blew my mind because I didn't even
think that was like that that wasn't
even an option for them you know there
are people like you have to think about
these things all the time and this is
how they have to live and it's because
of the prejudices and that's just like
that's really sad I know and everything
going on right now it just seems like
very I'm stopped so emotionally I'm
gonna stop talking like this but it's
very important it's just important and
the games like this that cover a wide
range a wide range of topics that people
find difficult to discuss and talk about
and understand because you can maybe
understand it to play in the game
Jesus right sorry
so I'm getting all emotional and let's
see what we did we decided to surrender
Oh actually most people did decide to
surrender you said it to force the
roadblock and Daniel accepted he decided
to force the robot and Daniel fries are
we trusting Daniel could've refused and
he could have refused our plea to
surrender as well that's interesting
good that's quite high the amount of
people who tries to force I guess it
depends on whether you've taught Daniel
to like do what's right as in by him not
being in crinum criminal and if you have
taught him that then I guess he he might
refuse he taught diners do his best to
follow the rules of society I've already
taught don't put himself in this brother
first yeah I guess I did teach him to
force a society which I'm up there are
hardly evolved at the same time it's
like do some kill or hurt other people
don't really care about you know all the
mundane stuff but that yeah oh yeah
ninety percent of people did the
treasure huh of course three percent of
it three percent gave up because they
couldn't find that Trebek treasure
because it was so hard to find it's hard
you overall got closer to Karen yeah
yeah you wrote a carrying notes
you said farewell to Arthur and Stanley
of course he said farewell her Joanne
we hugged Karen you into being too calm
Diego in the cells yeah definitely
he's just gonna yeah me make matters
worse anger doesn't well violence
doesn't really help
anger understand you freed the Mexican
couple yes you didn't open the couple's
so you asked Daniel to open the
vigilante cell seventeen percent of
people get done yeah and I'm gonna do
that twenty percent of people hurt the
vigilantes damn yeah I mean all these
percentages I do you find this bit
really interesting because it's like
you're seeing the consensus of what most
people deem that they want to do or how
they want to play the game and then you
can kind of compare how you play to them
hey Eddard
I like the ending you got yeah it was a
nice it was a good nice even though sad
ending but in the end American
melancholy of it was part of its PC in
my opinion I agree I actually do like
landing you even though the think about
but the fact that Sean didn't get life
I'm very happy about that and to see
that Daniel got to live with his
grandparents I'm got corrals and
graduate was ok and the mum was okay so
that's good Karen
is there anything that I didn't do
most of what other people did Oh dan
could refuse to free the vigilantes or
ah so I locked up the offices in the
closet
most people knocked out the offices like
Gabrielle you did that in you
you could kill them too
no I wasn't gonna happen to kill them
different
Wow Wesker says there were so many
where's endings so that's good to know
I'm probably gonna have to go and watch
them all actually I'm intrigued I want
to know what this other endings are but
thank you so much for finally going
through this journey with me sticking
around being patient and finding the--
watching the end of life is strange the
material we got there eventually told
you guys I wouldn't forget about it as I
said at the beginning of this video I
have put together a playlist of all the
other previous episodes so I'll add this
to that one and if anyone wants to recap
you can and I will share that link
probably on Twitter and my discord as
well and hey now I need to find a new
game to stream so I'm gonna rethink
about what I want to play I know a lot
of people won't you play last verse -
but I don't have that one so we'll see
but I'm kind of mad at me yeah I'm gonna
see what you wanna play and then I will
put up a poll on probably on youtube or
on Twitter so if you want to have a say
in that
keep an eye out if you're not already
you can follow me on Twitter and also
you can join the discord whether your
chat and
just talk about lies so I'll get you a
little link to the discord
[Music]
and thanks to don't knowledge yes
definitely thanks that don't not this
would not even be possible I wouldn't be
here stirring this game see if it wasn't
for them so okay thanks again for
spending the evening with me and I'm
gonna say goodbye to who I can see in
the chat thanks for watching me cry I'm
not making me feel like a massive baby I
will see you next week
as I said keep an eye out for that poll
you can help me decide what we're gonna
stream and I have been every night after
work doing a little bit more editing so
there is a new video coming soon so look
out for that okay goodbyes I'm Lana Beck
goodbye gara goodbye mantas goodbye
Daniel goodbye Jonathan goodbye I can't
visually um there's symbols symbols
goodbye deaf
goodbye a nick Egorov I didn't see your
Nicky just get here goodbye Wesker
goodbye Eddard goodbye Casper